Sometimes you don't have to implement an algorithm at all to reuse code. The
Comparable Interface is a very common interface. And implementing comparable
allows you to use handy pre-implemented algorithms for tasks like sorting.
Here's the documentation for Comparable. It's an interface that has exactly one
method, the compareTo method. Classes that implement the comparable interface
promise that they will implement the compareTo method. When you call
a.compareTo(b), it returns a negative number if a comes before b. It returns a
positive number if a comes after b. And it returns zero is a and b are exactly
equal. Once you implement the compareTo method, anyone coding can use it to
figure out what the natural order of objects in your class is.